[Music]
thank you
thank you um i'm british i'm not used to
high levels of enthusiasm so don't feel
that you need to clap again
but i've got lots to get through so so
from that show of hands it looks like
some people have used alexa and siri has
anyone built a voice interface
themselves before
a couple okay you could you can sleep
through the second half of this but wake
up for the conclusions
so a brief introduction to myself as
tessa said
i am a software engineer of 20 years odd
standing i started as a java developer
and then in 2008 i joined capgemini
which is an i.t consultancy so then my
work became project based and it gave me
an opportunity to branch out and play
with loads of different technologies um
javascript c-sharp apis low code no code
ethereum and then around 2015 i started
playing with voice interfaces which is
what i'm going to talk about today so i
think i'm myself as a bit of a of all
trades possibly master of none
and what we're going to do today is
we're going to look at how to build a
voice interface so first of all we'll
consider what to build and how to do it
and then
i could do a demo
or i could chicken out and play a video
and then we'll drill down a little bit
into the code and see exactly how it
works so
uh okay first of all what are we going
to build
um let's look at what we can use first
of all
and there are quite a lot of um
frameworks available particularly from
the big cloud vendors which allow you to
build your own voice interface
um and i had a look at through some of
them um alexa is is great because it's
very well documented there are loads of
quick start apps and tutorials to get
you going
and
as a java javascript developer it was
very familiar to me because you build a
model using json and then you can
integrate via an api to a back end such
as an aws lambda so you can write that
in node.js
and the downside of it is it's not
available in as many languages so you
can build apps in
english french german hindi italian
japanese portuguese or spanish at the
moment using amazon alexa
but if you wanted a wider range of
languages you can look at some of the
other offerings google's assistant is
quite specifically designed to build a
voice interface for your android app so
i've not done any android development so
i kind of stayed away from it a bit but
again as it's very you know as a
developer you'll be very familiar with
it you build a model in xml and then you
use rest apis to call the google back
ends and and you can use what alexa has
plus swedish korean vietnamese
indonesian danish and dutch so there's a
wider range of languages available
there's a siri kit to build
voice interfaces for your apple products
it uses swift if you're familiar with
that with the swift development language
and they claim to support 21 languages
as your claims will support 60 languages
but i don't know what support means
because there's a difference to having a
database that translates
60 language worth of phrases to actually
pulling out the meaning from those
phrases so i haven't had a look at them
though today's talk is going to be about
using alexa
and the next question is what is a good
app to build for voice interfaces
it's not as wide a range of use cases as
you might think
um
it would be a scenario where you're not
using your hands because it'd be much
quicker to press a button and often it's
quicker to actually type than it is to
interact with a voice interface
um so i was thinking you know what about
you know a chef maybe a chef needs a
recipe because they're busy cooking or
something like that and then i thought
well what about a therapist
because when you're talking to a
therapist you don't want to be typing
you want to be lying back you want to
close your eyes and sort of concentrate
on the inner you so i thought maybe this
would be quite a good app to build with
alexa
oh
i'm not going to offend you yet
uh hang on i've got a missing slide here
um
we need we need this one
let me just present it from here
hopefully it won't be missing here here
we are yeah so we want our therapist to
be at least pseudo-scientific
um
and so i was having a look around how
can i build
something that that does proper analysis
uh and there was a psychoanalysis called
carl young who you've probably heard of
and he proposed the theory of
psychological types
so he believed that you could loosely
classify people into a set of different
types and a lady called catherine briggs
and her daughter isabelle myers there's
a picture of them in the bottom there
they took carl's young idea and they ran
with it and they generated the
myers-briggs personality test you might
have heard of that you might have sat it
yourselves
uh but myers and briggs are quite
proprietary about their their questions
and their algorithms and they don't
allow people to to use it without paying
hefty fees
but luckily for us along comes the open
source community and the open source
community has created this the open
extended jungian type scales the
community version of the myers-briggs
personality test and so this is an open
source list of 32 questions and an open
source algorithm that will create what
it will define for you your personality
types so you can see some of the
examples of the questions there they're
kind of a or b style questions do you
prefer to make lists or do you rely on
memory and you need to answer these
questions on a scale of one to five so
if you always make lists you would
answer one if you always rely on memory
you would answer five and there's the
option to pick values in the middle if
you're not sure
and then there's an open source
algorithm so if you disagree with it you
can submit a pr to the to the open
source project um which will assign you
a personality type so these again these
are the opposite pairs so we've got your
you could be introverted or extroverted
sensing or intuiting feeling or thinking
or perceiving or judging and those those
sets of letters would then
group together to form 16 possible
combinations
so now it's time to offend you all i
thought how can i make this a little bit
more technology specific and i thought
maybe i could group these personality
types into software engineering
personality types so maybe i thought if
you're a server-side developer like
myself you might be a little bit more
um kind of
um introverted perhaps if you're a
front-end developer you're more on the
design side you're a bit more creative
perhaps an agile coach you're more
balanced you see the bigger picture
perhaps you're you're devops and you
like to be really in control or maybe
you're really into new tech and you're
really enthusiastic and outgoing about
about these things so um what i've built
is a personality skill that will run
through the open extended jungian type
scales questions
and decide for you what kind of a
software engineer you might be
so now comes the tricky bit the uh the
type scales require an answer in a scale
of one to five but if you're speaking to
alexa and she says do you want to make
lists or do you want to rely on memory
you're not going to answer four you're
going to go
oh well i probably would make lists you
know you're going to speak english so
how can i translate oh sorry not
necessarily english whatever language
you speak you how can i translate that
to the one to five scale
and the interesting thing about working
with the voice interfaces is how much
context you lose
because um basically what you'll get
through to your back end while you're
writing your code is just the text that
the voice interface has captured so
volume is lost for example so we can't
say right well they said that really
loudly so they must be really positive
we've lost that information we've lost
pauses so if they spend a while going
oh let me think about that that context
is lost as well and all the filler words
the um well that kind of word that we
could use to say okay they're not so
sure about this all that context is lost
so i couldn't rely on anything like that
to convert the text to the number scale
so what i decided to do was to add a
secondary question to each question and
capture the response to that and run
some sentiment analysis across the
answer so
if i say do you prefer to make lists or
do you rely on memory and you say i
prefer to make lists my follow-up
question will be well how often would
you reply that way or are you sure about
that and then i'll capture the response
and run some sentiment analysis upon it
and then if the analysis is positive i
can up your score and if it's negative i
can make your score more neutral
that's the plan
so to use a sentiment analysis api is a
simple matter of calling the api but i
think it's quite nice when you do use
these apis to think about well what's
actually going on in the background here
and
if you think about how you might perform
sentiment analysis on a phrase and and
the whole background of the uh the topic
of sentiment analysis is really quite
mind-bogglingly complicated so we're all
quite familiar with how you might simply
break down a sentence with the concepts
of nouns and verbs but that doesn't
really help us get to the sentiment of
what somebody's saying
and i had a brief look at the kind of
top level subjects that that
back up sentiment analysis and it is
quite terrifyingly complicated so
there's these concepts of
word segmentation about so we've got the
example here the word studies in the
word studying we know that it's the the
same core roots but how can a computer
figure that out and the idea of stemming
is to say well you take the first bunch
of letters that are the same but um the
idea of lemmatization is to go a little
bit beyond that and to say okay well
yeah so we've got study with an eye and
study with a y but i know
through inference and reading the
dictionary that in fact these are both
from the verb to study so it's quite
complex even breaking down the sentence
and then you get to trying to figure out
the sentiment of that sentence so you've
got the polarity the positivity and
negativity of certain words sometimes
it's easy with the yes and no and
sometimes it's it's just not easy you
know if my son says to me that's sick i
don't know what he means he's probably
mean something positive but how do i
know to take it that way
and then there's um
everything that you're
picking up from sentiment is
subjectivity so you can't just rely on
the word good being positive because
somebody might be saying good grief and
so they're not being positive at all
and then you have to consider um are
they comparing something with something
else you know if i say my phone is
better than nothing that's not
necessarily a very positive thing for me
to say about my phone and then is there
implicit information in the sentence so
you know if you say something is great
for the budget you're not necessarily
saying that it's good value but you
implicitly implying that it's quite
cheap whereas if i say oh that's a cheap
phone then i'm being very explicit with
the information
emotion detection as i said that's quite
difficult with
the apis because we've lost any things
like tones and nuances but then there's
the intent what is this person trying to
convey are they a news reader or are
they trying to suggest something to me
so the background of the individual can
apply to the sentiment analysis as well
and then you get to the really hard
stuff so you can see we're standing on
the shoulders of giants when we use
these sentiment analysis apis and
there's huge amounts of work that have
gone into figuring out how to use
languages
i like to think about how it actually
works behind the scenes so
most of them should work with
a neural network that's been trained
you can you can build your own there's a
python library the nltk where you can
build your own natural language
processing toolkit
or um the easiest way is to use
third-party apis and i like to think
that the api is perhaps it's just a
phone line that goes through to an old
people's home and they just pick it up
and go yeah that sounds positive because
i think that would be a lot cheaper and
easier to implement
okay
so let's have a look at what this
application looks like and we've got two
options here either i could get a
willing volunteer for an audience to
come and be analyzed by alexa or i can
play you a video of my daughter going
through the process so if there's any
volunteers that would like to come up
and be analyzed
raise your hands
oh yeah okay lady on the beanbag
[Applause]
we've only got six percent batteries so
i hope this is great okay
so um this this you can see is the alexa
development environment it's a web-based
ide um and i can i can just launch
and
be my side a twist
and hopefully this will play
check we've got internet
i don't have sound
yeah
if you got sound from the laptop
because that should have played a sound
yeah it's there okay
um
so how you need to talk to it actually
you need to hold the button down and
then speak so if i just show you good
start quiz
and then it will pick up your words and
then unfortunately you can't hear it but
you'll have to read the blue text here
is what alexa is saying so she's going
to ask you some questions
do you prefer to make lists or do your
own memory so yeah just hold it down and
give your answer
are you sure about that yes i'm sure
okay
now are you skeptical or do you want to
believe
i'm very skeptical
okay
now how about time alone are you bored
by time alone or do you need time alone
i need time alone
are you sure about that
okay now do you accept things as they
are or are you unsatisfied with the way
things are
okay
now do you keep a clean room or do you
just put stuff wherever
i am
interesting
would you always answer that question
the same
answered way
would you necessarily say that all the
time
thank you for taking the quiz
your personality type is i s t j we
guess from this that your strengths lie
in server-side development
[Applause]
thank you so much
so that was only five questions out of
32 so unfortunately that isn't your real
personality type you'll have to go and
drill down into more detail but
maybe she just knew
but i think what we can see from that is
maybe it's not the best um voice
interface
and asking those double questions is
really tedious can you imagine going
through 32 of those
you'd have smashed alexa against the
wall before you got to the end i'm sure
um
so now what we're going to do is have a
drill down and have a look at the actual
code and see how this was done
um
so
whoo
where's my other slideshow that one
seems to be working a bit better
okay so first of all we're going to look
at the the levels of the um alexa skills
so there are basically three layers the
first layer the alexa voice services is
normally the piece that's built into
your hardware so if you buy an echo the
alexa voice services will be built in
you can download and install it or you
used to be able to
but what this piece does is it just
basically captures the voice so there's
this concept of awake word so
there'll be a microphone constantly
listening for the wait word um it's
alexa you can change it last time i
checked you could only change it to
computer though so there wasn't many
options
um and there are rules when to start and
stop the recording so some voice
interfaces will let you record
indefinitely i think siri used to do
that but alexa will only capture a small
amount of time so it won't consistently
listen and then what it will do is
create a sound file from what it's
captured and send it through to the
amazon server
so the server the next level is the
invocation model the alexa skills kit is
what the ask stands for and and i think
of this bit as kind of like the sieve
which takes the text file and sieves out
the words that it's going to pass
through to your back end for processing
so this is where it tries to pull out
the pieces that the user's interested in
and there are a few concepts that we
need to
know about when we're trying to
understand how to build an invocation
model so there's this concept of an
invocation phrase how is your user going
to start interacting with with your um
with your api so we had start quiz to
trigger the uh process and there's the
the concept of an intent and you can
think of an intent as mapping one-to-one
with a function that you're going to
write on the back end so if i wanted to
write something to turn the lights on
you know that intent would be the user
wants to turn the lights on and then in
my function i could program how to
actually do that
and so
related to this intent you can add a
list of utterances which is what you
think people might say to fulfill this
intent and you can give amazon a list of
quite a few of these and the more you
give the more amazon is able to
correctly interpret what your users are
saying so they're not essential but the
more you give the better it is so with
mine for example you might just give the
answer directly i like to make lists so
you might say i think i or you might
just say probably lists so for my
utterances i've got to pull out what do
i think they might say and define what
those core pieces of information are
then there's a concept of a slot so a
slot is a variable in in your intent
method
um
and so in my case the slots need to be
the a or b answers so they need to be
making lists or relying on memory and
your slots can have a type so this can
be very simple you know so if alexa says
to you do you want me to put the lights
on yes no that's a type and i know
there's only two variables that are
going to fit into it and it's nice and
simple but you can create your own
custom types which is what i had to do
for for my alexa skill so i had to
create custom types of all the possible
things that people might answer with so
we can have a look at the reams of jason
i created for that in a minute but
amazon has a lot of built-in types
more than you might think so there's a
built-in type for first names there's a
built-in type for cities there's a
built-in type for weather you know you
name it there may well be something that
amazon has already gone to the painful
trouble of
engraving every possible answer for you
so that's really great for now
so once you've pulled out from your um
file
of your sound file the words that are
actually relevant to your skill these
get sent through to the back end using
an api so you can wire anything into a
back end but um
being on the amazon platform it's very
easy to wire in an aws lambda so that's
what i did
um so
these are event driven functions you
need to define two methods you need a
can handle method which will say whether
or not
your back end can handle this intent and
then you need a handle method which will
actually complete the logic that you
want that intent to do
yeah so at this third point this is
where i could then call out to my
sentiment analysis apis once i had the
data
um
because we're developing in the cloud
security should always be at the
forefront of your mind so you link these
skills to your aws account
and it's very easy to use oauth
well it automatically uses o-auth
between the invocation layer and the
back-end layers
and and you can use aws roles and
permissions to allow it to speak to your
your your lambda layer
um and so as a generic rule of building
stuff in the cloud always use the
minimum permissions necessary you know
if if it only needs to read from a
database don't give it right access that
kind of thing so always bear security in
mind and keep things as locked down as
possible
right so if i switch back over to the
[Music]
amazon
ide here
you can see
we've got
our build view so the build view is
basically it's a front over the json
model that we have
for our api so we have our invocation
name this is what we say when we're
actually starting
the um
the skill and then you can see our
intents amazon will give you a bunch of
built-in intents here so we've got
cancel we've got help stop navigate home
those will have default functionality
that does pretty much what you'd expect
or you can change it so you can put in a
custom help message things like that and
then we've got that intents that i have
defined myself so we've got the quiz
intent here
here's my list of sample utterances what
people might say and all this does is
basically launches the application and
will answer ask the first question
so we can go and have a look at the
actual code behind the quiz intent here
so here we are so as i said we've got
the can handle method which says is this
a quiz intent if so i can handle it and
then we've got our handle method
um and and what the handle method will
do is basically get a question from my
array of predefined questions which are
in my model which is here so in the
model
in the model i've had to define
absolutely everything
possible
um so i've got all the possible answers
oh that's my jason isn't it the model
yeah here we are so there's all my
personality types and how they map
through
to uh software engineering types and
then i've had to create a model for all
the questions um
that i want alexa to ask
so start quiz simply pulls one out
and asks the user
uh and then the next intent that we've
got here is the answer intent so how's
the user going to respond they're going
to answer the question how are they
going to do that they might just say the
answer or they might frame it with a i
think or usually or something like that
so i tried to create some suggested
utterances
and then we've got a slot type here so
the slot type that i've called quiz
answer or a bit uninventive with the
names is of type assertion and if we go
down and have a look at the slots here
here's assertion
and i've had to create
a list of values for this slot based on
the outputs of the quiz so everything
that they might say
the actual
piece of information i'm interested in
so the bit memory or lists i've put it
into my slot type
and so then if we go and have a look at
the code
for the answering
it will pick up the answer
um it will
you get a session so you can store the
answers that user sets into your session
here so i'm basically just finding the
answer if they've answered on the
left-hand side i prefer to make lists
i'll give them a one otherwise i'll give
them a five and then i'm going to pull
from my interesting responses one of the
random answers so my interesting
responses oh i think they're also in
here
um
so interesting i see things that you
know things are therapists might say and
then it's going to ask that back to the
user
so then we can go back and have a look
at that assertion intent so this is when
the user is answering the are you sure
question so i created a custom slot
called a decision
and this is the utterances of how they
might use that decision
and i given the decision a slot type of
assurance and then i've tried to guess
the kind of things people might say i'm
very confident or probably yes no
putting in some of the answers that they
might give there
right so then going over to the code for
this one
so the assertion here's a really
complicated bit where i get the open
extended jungian type scales algorithm
so i've got my number first of all i'm
going to call out in this case i'm
calling amazon comprehend which is a
sentiment analysis
api from amazon so you just
set it up with your credentials and send
it
your data and then it will return
a string which says positive or negative
so i can extract one for positive and
minus one for negative it will also
return mixed or neutral but that's fine
i can just leave those as a zero
so then i'll change my score and set the
score here and then this is where i've
only asked seven questions because it
was extremely painful going through them
but it would actually be the whole
length of the array and then you go
through them all and you finally
calculate your answer
so yeah as you can see it's a really
nice idea to work with as long as you've
got internet access and you can test it
online as you saw with that lovely test
api that shows you exactly what the
different layers have captured and you
can see the json of what comes in and
out as well so it's really great to work
with from a from a developer point of
view
right let's go back to
the slides that work
right we looked at the code okay so
lessons learned um
when should we be using voice interfaces
so the first thing to think about is the
interaction is slow the triggering the
thing getting it to know what you want
it's always going to be quicker to click
a button and it's usually quicker to
type so the scenarios are is when
something isn't within hand reach or
when people are perhaps busy with their
hands
so um
it's quite good for a small input and
output for things you can't reach so the
one that we always use in our house is
turn the lamps on because instead of
having to go around leaning over each
individual lamp that single voice
command which can't really be
misinterpreted works quite well but as
you can see from our psychoanalysis that
double question piece of trying to get
enough information really really slows
it down so when you're thinking about
how to design a user interface you've
got to think about minimizing what the
user needs to say
and minimizing the sort of
openness for interpretation
so
what i think of as as the voice
interface development skills are
understanding conversation structure i
think there's quite a lot of
language knowledge that is necessary um
if you're going to build a voice
interface and this is obviously language
and culture specific i'm always thinking
of it in english but it's going to be
completely different in when you're
building interfaces in other languages
and this really important concept of a
closed question so um
you know if i say do you want t the
answer is yes or no pretty much isn't it
but if i say what do you want i can't
possibly try and encapsulate in my model
of intents and slots what your answers
might be because they're too great
and
amazon used to have the concept of
an open string literal so you could just
capture a bunch of text but they're
actually um
discouraging the use of that now just
because it just is too difficult to
process you need some context around the
words that you're capturing
and and i really think it works well to
use a bit of randomness um in in your
interaction model to give it a more
realistic feel so you know when my alexa
therapist is saying
you know are you sure about that if they
said the same thing every time it
wouldn't be as engaging as the fact that
i can change it out and say would you
necessarily say that all the time
instead so just a little simple piece of
don't just always say the same thing use
a random selection of things which can
mean which can convey the same closed
question can make it more realistic to
interact with
and then
just the golden rules of the internet of
things would also apply to voice
interfaces always consider security
because we're going over apis on the
internet and always have a manual
override you know if if the only way to
turn on your lamps is via alexa it's
going to drive you mad um and how many
of you got a lamp that works with a
special remote control and you lose a
remote control and that's it the lamp is
completely useless so there should
always be a button somewhere
um
and and then yeah be aware of offending
people the first time that um i tested
this on my software engineering manager
and classified him as a front-end
designer he's never forgiven me
so um yeah be aware that um you know
you're capturing data here you can be
capturing sensitive data you need to be
aware of how you store it how you treat
it
um
and whether there are any biases in the
way that you've written your code based
perhaps on your language or your culture
that
might not convey what you think to other
people
so that's it thank you very much for
listening this is the github repo
if you would like to
download the personality quiz and
subject your family to it
do have a go it's pretty straightforward
to use and i'll be around if you've got
any questions later
[Applause]
you